is there a way for people to kind of  present themselves in a manner that  embodies these traits without actually  being a terrible person i have a good  friend of mine a criminologist he has  coined this idea the dark gentleman a  guy who's maybe a little bit edgy  ambitious somewhat emotionally distant  but they know what they want using some  of those qualities to pursue what they  want while also having a soft side to  them but as an individual person you may  want to be more extroverted maybe you're  more of an introvert but you want to  make friends get promoted i think guys  can do this too maybe being slightly  more disagreeable while painting some of  the good guy traits